est-ce que votre actuelle partenaire
votre ex retourne son téléphone en votre
présence
sous l'oreiller quand elle dort
faut faire attention
[Rires]
alors généralement si pendant la nuit
elle prend son téléphone je te rappelle
après
je t'aime je t'aime c'est un petit
bonheur
la mienne a fait pas ça elle met sur
vibreur et elle s'en sert
[Applaudissements]
je ne savais pas que tu étais avec
Daniel Moreau
il y a des codes je sais pas comment ça
marche
[Applaudissements]
le truc de la calculaire
le mode calculatrice vous allez dans le
mode calculatrice love coach et en fait
vous faites un code et en fait derrière
la calculatrice vous pouvez mettre
toutes les photos
et là tu mets toutes les photos voilà
que tu veux pas que ta meuf voix c'est
tout le temps des divisions sur votre
téléphone
en tout cas j'ai divisé ton salaire
ça va être vite divisé tu vois non mais
quand vous avez pas Béatrice ça c'est
Chanel
Béatrice
elle est pas bien non j'ai une petite
histoire avec mon mon mari hier qui est
en voyage professionnel
[Applaudissements]
alors
hier soir je regardais
gentiment face à Baba n'est-ce pas et
puis vers minuit moins le quart je
reçois un appel de mon mari qui est en
déplacement professionnel et je décroche
à l'eau à l'eau et il ne me répond pas
et en fait il n'avait pas conscience que
son téléphone m'appelait
et j'entends de la musique à fond et un
moment elle a entendu bouffe-moi le cul
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
où il est dans un bon restaurant
des voix féminines
pas sûr c'était une ou plusieurs
je pense que tout de suite il faut le
tromper avec son meilleur ami Benjamin
Castaldi
[Applaudissements]
et donc
j'essaye de d'entendre un peu mieux pour
essayer de comprendre le contexte et
tout et puis finalement ça a raccroché
et en fait c'était en WhatsApp donc il
sait même pas qui vous donne mais quand
tu travailles alors là attention
attention et là je fais appel à un
professionnel
[Rires]
Béatrice il va rentrer tout à l'heure il
ne sera pas quand tu le sais donc
attention ne tombe pas dans le piège ne
lui dis pas tu m'as appelé son père
exprès chérie comment vas-tu ça a été
l'Italie
vas-y ça va ton séjour tu as bien
travaillé
Esposito tu sais le
fameux milliardaire italien
écoute on a vendu pour 100000 euros de
chaussettes en cuir
j'ai bossé toute la nuit j'ai bosser
toute la nuit écoute là vraiment je me
suis couché tôt hier en plus enfin j'ai
bossé jusqu'à 2h du matin après je me
suis je me suis couché vraiment dans cet
enfer vraiment
quoi
exactement
en coaching non non non c'est elle
d'abord moi je suis ton mari donc
attention là tu lui dis qu'est-ce que tu
as fait hier là il va te dire j'ai rien
fait tu es tranquille on a été dîner
avec le Gianni là et Jean Luca j'étais
KO et puis après j'étais chaos je suis
allé me coucher là tu as bien sûr
l'horaire de l'appel alors 23h30 23h45
s'il était en boîte à 23h45 généralement
cet été c'est qu'il est en train de se
faire astiquer la poire
[Applaudissements]
aux
[Rires]
je connais les gars je connais je
connais je connais les enquêtes donc je
te le dis Béatrice pour moi il faut que
tu te vends j'ai au plus vite
sache que si tu cherches des gens pour
te venger il y a le routier sympa quand
même
dépanner
double sens malgré je vais en séminaire
je me fais rincer si tu veux un séminer
avec l'abominablement plus le vert bleu
mais non non pas lui non non
ils font une fête
est-ce qu'il avait prévenu
elle m'avait non pas du tout absolument
pas ça va passer une bonne soirée chérie
je t'attends
il y en a un qui a passé un weekend de
merde
les vacances de la Toussaint commence
mal pour lui tu vois j'ai posé une
question à Béa bien sûr si il avait
l'habitude de faire pour son travail des
déplacements et après de faire le dîner
avec des gens de l'équipe ou des clients
des choses comme ça des déplacements oui
régulièrement
non en général il fait pas trop la fête
placement déplacement on sait ce que ça
veut dire je vais te dire quelqu'un qui
se déplace il se déplace pas pour
travailler il faut arrêter
je pense que oui
c'est un mec au Sénégal on l'a dit à
Jules désolé
je suis désolé non je crois pas moi
surtout c'est que toutes les personnes
qui font cette émission sont ou
deviennent cocu
[Rires]
ça va pas du tout
ça il va tomber mais tu le mets dans un
coin de ta tête tu sais que tu as un
joker ça veut dire que quand il grillera
en soirée avec Raymonde
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
ça me fait pas plaisir de dire ça j'ai
l'impression qu'il se fout bien de ta
gueule
la question la question d'après c'était
est-ce que votre partenaire actuel fait
souvent des soirées entre amis sans vous
abris
non je vais dire
merci
est-ce qu'en voiture il ou elle
déconnecte son téléphone de du Bluetooth
catastrophe c'est horrible le Bluetooth
c'est la pire invention
tu trouves toujours moi je vous avais
raconté
l'horreur
tu es le début des Bluetooth en plus
qu'on appelle la touffe bleue
et moi alors là mais quand ça résonne
dans toute la voiture il y a une meuf
qui t'appelle ta meuf ne connaît pas et
qui te dit salut c'est Gina et que sur
le truc il y a marqué SNCF
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
avoir des promos des trucs la réponse
c'est jamais si on veut partir
Pascal mais c'est la vie de couple c'est
pas facile parce qu'au début c'est tout
beau c'est tout rose et au bout de 10
ans on a plus les mêmes comportements au
début c'est l'amour avec un grand art au
bout de 10 ans c'est l'amour avec un
gros tas
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
j'ai l'impression de dérouler la vie de
Béatrice
est-ce que votre partenaire prend son
téléphone quand il va sous la douche
sous la douche
combien on a vu de cas comme celui-là il
était dans la douche
j'ai pris son téléphone et là tu es dans
la douche et tu sors tu es avec la
serviette et tu vois ta meuf qui fait
vraiment une totale
qui vont dans la dans la douche avec
leur téléphone c'est terrible parce que
c'est souvent pour faire des photos
coquines pour envoyer à leur valeur
franchement à mon avis
toutes les photos chelou que je reçois
sur les réseaux elles sont dans la rue
mais pas du tout il se passe quel
travail dans la salle de bain
mais encore faut-il avoir le code est-ce
que quelqu'un à votre code par exemple
même moi je l'ai pas
mais moi je n'ai pas que vous avez tout
Pascal sur ton téléphone si j'ai quoi tu
as un code sur ton téléphone bien sûr
mais c'est en fait c'est le téléphone
qui te le demande
c'est quoi l'intérêt
comme ça moi tu arrives ce soir fais
rien chérie tu vois il y a pas de coq
tu connais quand tu fais les coups de
bœuf avec ta meuf aussi vas-y
[Rires]
arrête de bouffe le téléphone comment tu
peux téléphoner
j'ai rien à [ __ ] mon téléphone
pour revenir à l'histoire de des 10 ans
entre le les coupes ou même 20 ans c'est
au début c'est compliqué parce qu'au
début tu lui dis la première nuit tu lis
par exemple qu'est-ce que tu veux ma
chérie une coupe de champagne 10 ans
plus tard c'est qu'est-ce que tu veux ma
chérie un orgasme
c'est pas facile
tous les couples qui nous regardent là
ce soir ce soir on va détruire pas mal
de clubs
tout le monde le voit ça c'est sûr le
mec qui nous regarde et que ça va c'est
dire que je l'ai fait il y a deux jours
ça
prend le toiture 100 fois toi je change
de code tous les jours bien joué avec ma
mémo mémoire j'ai une bonne mémoire donc
change de code tous les jours de
téléphone
comme ça genre à plat sur un asse
reprocher mais en fait le téléphone il
est en mode avion exactement ça n'aura
jamais
[Rires]
je vous jure que c'est vrai j'ai appelé
Apple pour savoir si on pouvait enlever
l'avion
mettre en mode avion mais l'enlever
alors je vais vous dire un truc il y a
mieux que le mode avion c'est aussi un
petit cadeau le mode lune
exactement
parce que personne ne le voit seul vous
voyez que vous recevez seul toi tu vois
que tu reçois les appels des messages là
vous parlez à des professionnels
je vous le dis attention maintenant on
voit quand la personne quand on vous
envoie des messages et la petite lune en
haut
dans la voiture
c'est moins connu la meuf elle boit le
malin maintenant ta meuf voit ça moi la
dernière fois
c'est la plus nul après manger
le téléphone c'est mieux que toi
excuse-moi c'est connu en l'une que toi
le téléphone excuse-moi peut voir à
distance que tu t'es mis en mode lune
par SMS
pas du tout tu dis que tu étais dans un
tunnel pendant très longtemps je l'ai
déjà fait
j'ai pas l'aller-retour et summerdes
très simple rester fidèle
toujours merder
je tape dans la barre
tu es en train de jeter un pavé dans la
mare et en plus c'est pas beau c'est pas
des mots que Béatrice je veux entendre
aujourd'hui
dernière petite question est-ce que
votre partenaire part au Sénégal sans
vous
plusieurs mois et vous dit qu'elle est
en train de préparer un mariage avec
vous qui n'arrive jamais témoigner si
vous avez été victime de ce genre de
supercherie
on vous attend d'un autre voyage
justement pas tout ouais
elle va où au Sénégal
mais moi ça fait deux mois que je t'ai
pas vu ma mère
tout le temps on a regardé face à Baba
elle était en tout cas je suis rentré à
la maison après face à là-bas et tu es
là
c'est bon quoi tu vois ça va